on s'intéresse à présent un
microphénomène à saint-pierre-des-corps
très régulièrement rue du colombier une
à deux voitures sont abandonnés même
emplacement en attente d'être désossée
sur place par qui veut d'où viennent ces
voitures et qui paye la facture pour le
recyclage légal réponse dans ce
reportage d'hélène chapelet ces voitures
sont arrivées ici sur leurs quatre roues
il y a quelques jours
comme beaucoup d'autres avant elle elles
ont été laissées sur un emplacement bien
précis dans une zone industrielle de
saint pierre des corps
leur démantèlement a ensuite été assurée
au fil du temps par des individus de
passage qui ont récupéré l'autoradio les
rouler phares et tout ce qui pouvait
l'être
une situation qui perdure depuis
plusieurs années en 2020 malgré le
confinement
cent cinquante deux épaves ont ainsi été
récupérés par la ville de saint pierre
des corps
une situation inextricable selon le
maire je vois pas comment pourrais-je
nourriture
sincèrement on peut pas être derrière
tout le monde bon c'est sûr quand on
quand on abandonne devenu une habitude
la solution la plus facile ça sera
encore la caméra surveillance mais bon
alors quand c'est évident que je voulais
c'est différent quand cette visite eu
d'incendié c'est différent pour le coup
il concédait véhicules qui sont mal
stationné ou que la personne est parti
en voyage quelques jours là pour le coup
effectivement ça se comprend difficile
de croire que ce sont les propriétaires
qui ont te même abandonné leur véhicule
en laissant la plaque d'immatriculation
ou le certificat d'assurance visible
derrière le pare brise
si tel est le cas ils devront par la
suite assumer les frais de fourrière
car après un délai réglementaire de 14
jours minimum
ces véhicules partent en fourrière le
temps pour la police d'identifier à qui
ils appartiennent
si ces voitures ont été déclarées volées
c'est l'assurance auto de leurs
détenteurs qui réglera la note
dans cette hypothèse les véhicules qui
est retrouvé et cédé à la compagnie
d'assurances qui elle
dans ce cas là à l'obligation si le
véhicule est hors d'usagé de faire
transporter le véhicule dans un centre
de agréé pour la dépollution et pour le
recyclage en moyenne 265 voitures sont
déclarés volés chaque jour en france
des chiffres en baisse constante en
indre-et-loire en 2018 les services de
police et de gendarmerie ont enregistré
3 1978 vols liés à l'automobile ses 211
de moins que l'année précédente